hey guys hope we going it's Justine
today we are going to be making
something this is kind of like a
two-part video first we're going to do a
taste test of the new fireworks or you
know there's no s so just a single work
just popping candy inside so that should
be exciting
after the taste test we are going to be
making a firework Oreo cake it's a no
big cake
so there will be no baking involved
fingers crossed it works out also to go
with this dessert I'm so excited about
this baby yoga work we're gonna be
integrating pop rocks into our dessert
today will we die today
you never know shut up Justine start
cooking prepare the chocolate waiting
according to directions on the box set
aside in the fridge hmm okay according
to the box
two cups cold milk beat it beat it yeah
nice direction five minute pudding
direction that's it one two pudding will
not set if made with soy milk that's a
good note
five minutes footing why do with the
rest of my minute all right you know
what I don't know how many minutes that
was but it's enough minutes for me
putting in Oh my favorite part this is
industrial I could blend a body in here
and the fire is that I'm not sure I love
blending buys it's my weekend activity
yes has anybody seen Santa Clarita diet
because if you haven't watch it I am
drew Barrymore let's give it a check now
so this has a little firecrackers in it
I can hear it inside my head I don't
know if you guys can hear it feel it
inside my head I can hear it if they
find our Oriole approximate whatever
it's like unexpected and because I
swallow some of it I've been going down
my esophagus and it's crackling and
popping this thing is still freaking
futuristic that better oh I'm just to
put this on we're going to pulse it up
[Music]
this is good enough to be fair
Tiffani diems I guess a meeting club
will actually think this is the large
fair
let's milk you up well that's boiling a
mix this into here this is healthy I
love fitness there's something that I
meant to address the beginning of the
video is if you're wondering between why
is your shirt look like it's destroyed
I want this shirt like this this is how
you know you're a true idiot you buy a
t-shirt it looks like it's been
absolutely destroyed oh it's snap
crackling and popping because of the
butter I'll listen I'm putting the
microphone close to you can you hear it
it sounds like Rice Krispies
look at this workstation look how I'm
working this is the most organized
choking show not a show you've ever seen
now we need to grease our pan cooking
fry is my answer to everything
Oh is your door squeaking let me get
that for you oh no this a piece of my
expensive roof shirt jeez Oh give it a
nice press so you just want to line the
bottom of your grace pants with your
cookie mixture there we go that's our
base of our cake I think I'm gonna try
to put some pop rocks in it hopefully
they don't pop yet we're not ready for
them
oh yeah I feel like my teeth are
breaking nice layer of that is my head
making that noise or is my cake so
during one cup of cool hwhip
alright little extra because I like
extra we're mixing our cream cheese our
sugar and cream until light and fluffy
all right cream cheese go in
look let's play cinema oh yeah that's
gonna work right
probably should have used the mixer so I
cleaned everything up and I was so
excited with the outcome of my cream and
I realized that I forgot the heavy
whipping cream that I needed Paul is
right what's this this is for alcohol
which one you want stable so do you
think so we're going to find out to
Tibbals to test
Tibbals of heavy cream ah perfect now we
know now we're going to take this and
we're going to press it into our mix
that we have coolants in the fridge
what's the head pop rocks in here before
we close up shop wow this is beautiful
it sounds like it's cooking itself can
swap this little mixture and see here
okay well this isn't cooking it's it's
just crackling oh my god it's really
good let's put some more on here we're
putting we're gonna putting here
okay putting layer done all of this
would be the best fireworks Oreo cake
that anyone's ever made because I don't
want to dirty another pan I'm just going
to mix it in here we're gonna put a lot
in here because this is our topping and
this is the first thing that your party
that you're going to see and they're
going to be like wow how is this
dangerous now we're going to add this on
as our final little delectable layer I
mean this cake is talking to me we are
having work it's so loud I can't believe
it it was gonna be crazy actually
there should be a flavor on it on top of
also some more hurt oh my gosh they're
all making noises over here so I put my
delicious mixture in the fridge to cool
it's still making noise this is creepy
snack packs grab them share them diplom
caicos if you can't that's something you
can't make up fences originally was an
Oreo fireworks themed cake I'm going to
put a little mini Oreos on it a little
red and the blue do not look good
together but sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I'd also like to note that I didn't
realize how it's fun to pop rock words
put this in perspective I would like you
to what I'm shooting today I'm not gonna
have time to go down to the candy store
and buy pop rocks
so I sent a postman and I get the final
bill
it was $80 per freaking pop rock I about
lost my mind I mean granted we probably
got a 30-30 pack but like that's a lot
of money so we're going to make this
cake we're getting our money's worth is
today the day of all the things that
make this kitchen and this is all I'm
going to go out so here's the good news
I'm not alone nathan is here and so is
Sarah which means we are going to do the
same stuff I mean they don't have to do
things I'll definitely take one for the
team but I think that this is something
that you should definitely bring to a
picnic especially like you the fourth of
July coming up your friends will love it
come join the fun we just need to kick
school this is a way to go you're right
you let your bite just put that in your
mouth like that
no no I'm serving oh look at that
that's actually holding together me
yeah and see the thing we how many pop
rocks are you're gonna get no I mean the
whole top is just yeah oh it's a crunchy
oh wow wow this is something I'll do the
same okay yep all right here we go one
two three hmm has a very funny situation
hmm out there it has kind of the laid
out I think that might be a breeze on my
sweatshirt I'm sorry that's definitely a
piece of your sweatshirt in my cake yeah
oh wow yeah I guess more I got your
blood sweat tears and shirt into the K
yeah I'm sorry it's delicious though
it's actually pretty good
it's weird though it does pop in your
throat yeah so so what's this layer
underneath club rocks like what cream or
something should the bottom layer is the
Firecracker firework Oreos are very
lended and then cream cheese Cool Whip
with more fireworks pop okay huh I mean
it's just layered with tons until the
pop rocks just a huge bite of this see
what of just the top layer yeah Wow
oh my god Evelyn burning classic in my
mouth like what God look we're in
glasses with a purpose
and it doesn't stop once you eat it it's
like there's hidden pop rocks and my
teeth mm-hmm the cake that keeps on
taking mmm keeps on popping all right
fruit thank you mm-hmm it's an
interesting mixture well that's it this
is the Oreo firework cake this is kind
of a recipe that I developed in
partnership with a googol recipe but it
was really was supposed to be a no bake
mitt lasagna cake but really yeah this
dis tournament you took complete
creative control I admire that thank you
I mean it might be you know just a
creative direction that I went down like
a the wrong way but it's here it's
actually pretty good though ya know I
actually liked it like I ate half of it
I know it's awful I know you do I feel a
sugar coma coming about mm not cool have
a full thanks for watching thanks for
shooting thanks to her taste testing and
we'll see you guys next video there's
anything that you would like to see me
bake in the future leave in the comments
below and I'll see you later
oh this is the diaper
[Music]